Mặt lãnh đạo đàn nhắn ớc, quân nguy trúc gân, người lấy chúc tốt đẹp nhất đến quan thể cán bộ chính xí quân nhắn chuyến nhập công nhận và viên chức Quốc phòng của quân Trung 2 Quân.
Tổn bị thư tô lầm nhắn mạnh, hơn 20 năm qua, giới sự lãnh đạo chỉ đạo việc nối chực tiếp về mọi mặt của đàn, sự quan tâm động viên chỉ đạo của chủ tiệt của chiến miên, sự quan lý điều hành tập trung thông nhắc của nhắn ớc, thường suyên chực tiếp là quân nguy trúc gân bộ Quốc phòng, sự yêu thương đủ mọng súc đỡ của nhân dân cả nước và mặt mẹ của tế,
hải quân nhân dân Việt Nam ngày càng trường thành lớn mạnh, luôn hành thành thẳng lợi mọi nhiều buồn, lập được nhiều thình tích xuất sắc và nặn bịt xuất sắc trong chiến đấu khốn luyện sẵn sẵn sẵn đấu, lâu đậu sẵn xuất, công cá và làm nhiều buồn Quốc tế.
Lê hoàn thành xuất sắc nhận vụ được sao, tổng mỹ thư yêu cầu quân Trung hải quân tập trung quán chịch sâu sắc, nằm vẫn quan điểm được lối chua chứng của đàn chính xác phát rộn của nhắn lớc, về quân sự Quốc phòng trong tâm là những tư vĩ nhận thức về Quốc phòng vào vệ tổ quốc, theo nghị quét đại hội mối bốn của đàn, chủ đậu nghiên cứu nắm chắc tình hình, kịp thời tham mưu, lề sớt với đàn nhắn lớc, quân nguy trung ngân bộ Quốc phòng, những dài pháp, đúng, chung, vừa bảo vệ bứng chắc chủ quyền biển đạo của tổ quốc, vừa
vất bố trường phá bình, or Đéc, trên biển để sề sật phát trịn đất nốt.
Gái thập trịn, các kênh bụt của phòng ăn đi, đúng ngoại, kinh tế, chủ đậu nghiêm Cuồn tham yêu đều s nova, các trại pháp, phát trịn,
vвин vướng kinh tế biển, em với bảo vệ chủ quyền biển với đối của ra trên biển,гляд vui đồng tố đạt,
vồn lực đẩu nguanh tẹp để ăn xây rử phục kinh tế của phòng trưởng ra, con chủ hải quan, mỗi lần lớn lượng ngon
có là điểm tượng vũn chắc trong gia đình vũn khơi bám biển xây dựng thế chạp phòng thuận ra,
bởi thế chạp lòng ra trên biển ngày càng vũn chắc.
Lòng tốt cũng đã hợp tắt của tế về biển đạo,
đối ngoại vũn phòng của quân lỗi hại quân các nước.
Khi thời gian quyết các hôm nay này xuy bảo vệ vũn chắc chủ quyền.
Quuyền chủ quyền tài phán và lấy cuộc ra giữ vũn muu trường hòa bình.
Chứ biển.
Chào tạng dễ kiểu an ngùng lực lượng vũn chắc nhân dân lần thứ 3 cho quân trùng hại quân bộ Quốc phòng.
Tổn bị thư tốt lắm, bị thư quân lỗi chung ngân nghiệp và đánh ra cao sự lãnh đạo chỉ đạo xấu sắc
hiệu quả của quân lỗi chung ngân bộ Quốc phòng.
Sự quân tâm phối ở và tạo điều kiện thật lợi của các măn bộ ngành chung ngân diệu phân.
Để hại quân nhân dân Việt Nam ngày càng lớn mạnh về mọi mặt,
đáp ứng yêu cầu nhận vũn chắc tình hình mới.